We'll start off by looking at take recorder.
So take recorder essentially enables you to record quickly and iteratively inside of Unreal Engine.
So you can easily record animations from motion capture linked to characters in the level.
You can see these two meerkats here.
We can record their performances and grab the animations from those performances.
And then you can also use live link data for future playback.
So recording the takes and adding them into Sequencer, which you can see at the bottom here.
It allows for productions of all sizes and any number of takes can be accommodated.
So it's a really great tool, especially when working in larger teams.
And we'll dig into some of those workflows as we go here.
So we can actually find our take recorder window.
If we go to the window button in the top of the editor.
And if you're using more recent versions when Unreal Engine, I believe 5.1 or later,
you can actually just type in the take recorder and it should filter through the available windows and find take recorder.
Alternatively, you can browse through the submenus and find take recorder there.
But essentially the interface, once you have it pinned to your editor somewhere, you can see we have 10 key areas to look at here.
So we've got the create new take button, pretty self-explanatory there.
And then you can also review a previous recording or even start a new recording using that take as a base.
So you can kind of layer up the take recording, as we mentioned in the previous slide.
You can also show and hide the take browser, the level sequence and also the take recorder project settings up at the top right there.
And then we can also with the big red button there, record the take that we wanted to capture.
We have some timestamp and frame rate information displayed to make sure you're aligned correctly with what you're capturing.
And then we also have the various sources for recording.
I'll talk about how to add sources to the recording in a short while here.
But you can see that we've added two meerkats in this example so that when we press record,
any kind of performance data they're presenting to the end user in real time, that will all be captured,
which then can be played back offline.
Then we have in section nine, we can add a little description for our take, especially when you're working with multiple takes.
This can be very useful to add some descriptors there.
And of course, in a similar vein, number 10 allows you to edit the slate take name and number to make sure all the takes are being organized correctly.
You can find some additional resources at the link at the bottom of the page here,
which will dig into any additional information you might need to know about take recorder.
So as we said, the most common usage of take recorder will be projects using Live Link.
So because take recorder enables you to quickly record performances using Live Link, it's an easy way to update and iterate on previous takes.
So you can see that this is how we might add the various actors to the performance.
You can either click on the source here and from actor and then it'll allow you to select any actors that are currently in the in the world map to this take recorder.
You can also drag and drop from the world outline panel in your editor.
You just drag and drop them into this actor area here and it'll add them there.
And then you also just need to make sure you update the take recorder record type to the appropriate settings.
So you can edit a certain amount of properties here.
So you can see that we have this meerkat selected and we say, OK, how do we want to record?
Do we want to reduce any key information? Do we want to record parent hierarchy?
But then also we have tracks that are specific to this actor type.
So in this instance, it's the blueprint meerkat.
So do you want to record whether it's hidden or not hidden?
Do you want to record any attached tracks, transform tracks, things like this?
Essentially, you can capture all the data and even if you don't feel like you need it right now, you can use it later today.
Now, the flip side to that little caveat to add is that you don't want to record too much data that the data becomes overwhelming.
So if it's just content that you may just never end up needing, you can go ahead and untick that and it won't capture those properties.
However, it's always good to have some information to work with.
So as we said, we can layer up multiple takes and so you can record as many takes as you need by repeating the process or using existing take as a base, as we showed in the UI section just on the previous slide.
So you can see a few settings that you may want to look at and dial in.
You can even change things like the countdown time.
So if a three second countdown is a little bit too short or maybe too long, you can adjust that to your preference.
And of course, we've got the additional resources at the bottom there for you to dig into further properties.
The way we might start thinking about capturing both cameras and actor performances is through the use of some external hardware.
So you could use cine cameras, which can be genlocked to the editor and you can record directly through the cine camera via pixel streaming is also a possibility if you're using an iPad.
So if you want a slightly lower cost, more low cost solution, you can download the virtual camera app to the iPad.
It is a free app supported by Epic on the App Store.
Alternatively, there is a paid app on the marketplace for an Android capture app.
So just check what kind of motion recording setups you prefer.
It's going to depend on the project size and scale.
But needless to say, there's a multitude of performance capture and camera motion recording options available.
Then we also have some actor performance recording.
Maybe you want to use something like Xsense or some other kind of performance capture setup.
There's a few different options on the market there.
And again, it depends on the budget and the scalability of the project, what you're trying to achieve, depending on what approach you decide to take there.